and thank you so much to the conference
organizers
and to my colleague dr marcel perez
gentile
for the invitation to join you for my
first lab roots event
i wish to start with the disclaimer that
the views represented here today are my
own
and based upon many years of reflection
and discussion with valued colleagues
that are veterinarians
animal research staff members icof
professionals committee members and
scientists dozens of people before me
for dozens of years have been discussing
variations of what i will share today
in the hope that we continue to keep our
lines of communication open
to better understand our own as well as
others perspectives
so just for some overview today on what
we're going to cover
the presentation will have some learning
objectives i'll share the background on
the intersection of art as a perspective
on evaluating the three r's we'll also
review the classic 3rs for animal use
and welfare
and bring in some historical perspective
we'll touch on limitations of the rigid
interpretation of the 3rs classic
concept
and how to think about analyzing animal
research ethics with the progressive
r's lens and lastly if time permits i'll
touch on a couple of case scenarios that
have just been presented in the last
month
january 2021 of how we maybe can apply
these progressive 3rs
so i have to give a little bit of
background on why
i decided to bring art into this notion
today
so during the pandemic like many of you
there was a lot of time i gained back
with the loss of other activities
and in that time i found the barnes art
museum that had online courses
and i enrolled in a few of their
lectures i never really had time to
study art before
and i learned about the collection
that's at the museum and about painters
like surat
modigliani and bingo who i'll highlight
today
i was still in the midst of these art
classes when
i was reached out to by the labyrinths
group
and asked to participate in this
conference and i was known
it was known to me that it was going to
be about the three r's that's what
marcel had shared
and i did agree to talk on the condition
that i could discuss the three r's more
philosophically
as a critique and a conversation really
with the audience
as i thought about the framework of the
three r's juxtaposed against my ongoing
art classes
and the frames that i was seeing from
artistic masterpieces
these ideas started to merge in my brain
so when analyzing animal research
and the cost or harm to benefit
considerations
the viewpoint is widely dispersed
depending upon whom the observer is
are you a member of the public are you
in the media
how about an anthropologist a
statistician a veterinary technician
each of these stakeholders in animal
welfare will come to the three r's with
their own perspective
and no one person can really make the
determination about that harm benefit
analysis
without further discussion and
understanding of multiple perspectives
we are part of a scientific community
that has the privilege in our country to
deliberate on moral issues
and when we have the responsibility to
keep objective facts and subjective
feelings and balance
when ethical considerations are involved
we each may see things through what you
see on the slide here these different
frames
depending on the scenario that's
presented to us however i feel that
keeping things
boxed into just a frame like the term
framework itself
potentially inhibits our ability to
think more broadly about the balance of
ethics
welfare benefits and science
so in looking at these frames it struck
me
in my art classes that it looked a lot
like
pictures of the french salon now i
hadn't heard of the french salon before
so
give me a moment it was held in paris
it was a state-sponsored huge art
exhibition held annually with all
academy trained artists
it was the official venue for displaying
the styles of the time
it was held in paris beginning in the
1660s and arguably was the greatest
annual art event in the western world
between about 1750
and 1900 so in my analogy
if you'll indulge me here we are this
audience in the picture today
on the floor we are the scientists the
animal care workers the public the
ethicists
the regulatory overseers we're all
standing looking at the walls plastered
with this art
we're looking at the art of science the
art of animal welfare
the art of the species that we interact
with our perspective on how and where to
look
in this grand room really depends on
where we can get our best views
and it differs on where we're standing
on that particular day
so my point here is that the three r's
are not stagnant
they're not just two-dimensional they
demand continuous review
perspectives discussion and evolutionary
interpretation
so before we go much further into this
presentation i just want to remind
everyone
about the great number of discoveries
that have happened with the benefit of
animal research
and this is i just selected a few from
the sbr
website on all of these which have been
granted the nobel prize in medicine
they've proceeded and occurred after the
inception of the 3rs
which occurred in the mid-1900s all of
these
included animal models for the discovery
and if you want to see more information
about them certainly please do visit the
sbr research site
as recently as last year at the bottom
bullet here crispr pass technology
received the nobel prize in chemistry
it's a technology that will have huge
impacts and already has on animal models
that we use
and i'll share a case study at the end
that involves crispr
so just very briefly since many of you
know this but i think it never hurts to
just revisit it
the origin of the classic three r's as
i'll term them so these were
established by russell and birch they
were
british scientists that were writing a
book and in 1959
they did state that the scientific
excellence of what would come from work
and the humane use of laboratory animals
would be inextricably linked their aim
at the time was to improve animal
welfare with the 3r
simply as a launch pad for the future
development of a
discipline that they were looking at
thinking about new scientific methods
and medical discovery
so what has occurred with the three r's
listed here
replacement reduction and refinement is
that they have been increasingly applied
as the penultimate ethical benchmarking
tool
against which high quality science in
the academic and industrial sectors
gets measured and there's increasing
focus on thinking about alternatives to
using animals at all
however it's not really all that they
represent and it's important to recall
that there was never a mention of
alternatives in the initial work by
russell and burch
the concept in fact remains more
prevalent than ever
so the 3rs just has grown as really kind
of a branding
in global discussions related to humane
animal use and aspects of research
and teaching and testing but i want to
point out that they're a touchstone
in terms of refinement reduction
replacement
they're not the end-all be-all and i'll
have us think a little bit more
progressively as we go through the talk
today
so why would they be challenged we know
that
they are a contribution to the
evaluation process
we can appreciate they are not the sole
ethical consideration for animal welfare
but understandably at times they have
been and um so i'd like to kind of
in the idea of thinking about them in a
pictorial sense
is show them as an umbrella so this
would be the three pieces there's three
leaves here of the umbrella and there's
one hand holding it the one perspective
of the person that might be looking at
that
so i want to think about more broadly if
we have the three r's
and here they are again from before like
what would happen if we actually put
them in each of these
umbrella angles to think about them
as i've mentioned um it's a lot in the
wording
so at the times that i feel that 3rs
have been misappropriated
it's as if one of the rs has been pulled
out and really focused on
and and somehow deemed that we maybe are
as a scientific
biomedical veterinary community not
accomplishing things
and not progressing if we aren't
accomplishing an
3r in each of our experiments in some
way um there's a attempt
an idea that we might be failing um and
i object to that strongly
i mean it's sort of like we looked back
and these were coined in 1959 right
so we wouldn't expect an infant if it
was born to predict its future life
course so
we can't really continue to hold the
three r's in their nation state
if we accept that that concept has
matured and they're really kind of past
middle-aged now
quippy acronym but it represents so much
more
to the benefit of ongoing scientific
discovery
so for example it's not necessarily an
accomplishment for human benefit
if we use fewer animals in the spirit of
reduction
when we have more disease and illness
and it's not a failure if we have to
look at more than just one sex which
again would be more animals male and
female
and it's not a catastrophe if we don't
replace animals because we have to have
an intact body system
and measurable responses for
observations interventions and outcomes
i doubt there's anyone that would refute
that the classic 3rs definitions need to
be expanded
and certainly we have to realize there's
been a massive transition in how the
world views science discovery and animal
use since their creation
so the three r's we'll hear often
referenced to as an ethical framework
but i would ask you to think about them
just as a tool one
of many that should be used by the
scientific community to assess the cost
benefit
also called the harm benefit of using
animals in scientific discovery
so back to thinking about our art if we
tick of the three r's up on the screen
here
we can overlay them and in doing so
i want to share with you a little bit
about a triptych here another van gogh
piece
so this is a postman it's very famous
many of you will probably recognize this
that one of these hangs in the barnes
museum in philadelphia
right now for most of 1988
van gogh rented a room in france in
aurel
near the train station and he saw this
gentleman
at the local pub this is joseph roland
he was a male handler
they became good friends and over time
van gogh painted him
multiple times all was with that dark
blue uniform of the postal
service but what he was able to do and
like i'd like to draw as an analogy
is he took what would have been an
ordinary kind of salt and pepper beard
and turned it into this brilliant ocean
of color
so if we think about paintings as a map
the three r's are also a map
they're a guide a guidance to us they're
not set in stone
each time we might look at them there be
a different perspective
and we think about them much like art
this is a time stamp of what was going
on in france in
in the 1880s just like the three r's
we have to look at them and place them
in context of what's happening right now
what our contemporaries are doing we
think about them with respect to social
problems and social changes
and other things that are present and
ongoing
i have a great quote by the american
artist jeff coons who says i'm going to
ask you to be courageous
confident and not think of art as the
finished product but as a process of
becoming something faster
and again i think there's great
analogies here with the three r's
so we then transition the three r's i'm
going to have you go back to the
umbrella analogy with one person holding
it
and open up the umbrella so now we have
a lot more space in which to work we're
not restricted by that framework
that seems to be a very common concept
and discussion
and i also want to point out that under
this sort of expanded view that gives us
much more space to think and work
in we have more than one hand holding
the handle
these are all the stakeholders we need
to be having group discussions about the
three r's
to rigorously evaluate the science the
proposal design
the species the number of animals
outcomes and impacts
so there are a number of additional
important concepts that appeared after
the three r's and the three r's really
didn't even take root until
the you know the 1990s honestly but in
that time from 1959 and onward i just
wanted to give you
some more of the synergy that comes from
what the 3r started
and the three r's themselves to be
honest we don't have time to go into all
the history but
they came after a lot of other
discussions about thinking about animal
welfare
so the five freedoms many of you have
heard of them they
outline five aspects of animal welfare
they're under human control and
they were developed initially by the uk
government in response to livestock
husbandry
they themselves didn't get formalized
until about 1979
when animal welfare groups in the uk and
the royal society for the prevention of
cruelty to animals started talking about
them more so
an additional concept was that of the
three s's
i'm really grateful
so these initially were coined by carol
newton and they weren't widely embraced
either until the 1980s
so carol was a scientist and she
presented this idea at an ilr conference
in 1975
and they really were only presented in a
talk and they were later discussed by
other scientists
and it wasn't until 2016 that dr smith
and hawkins
decided to write them up again so in the
concept that she shared
of good science this is naturally the
aim of all scientists
still is was then and will be
so in essence we're talking about
experimental design to reduce variation
permit effective analyses and obtain the
most information with the greatest
certainty in the shortest amount of time
her idea of good sense described an
essential tool in lab animal science
in that the right animal is used for the
right reason
this is another three r's the right
animal and the right reason
that was coined at a 1970s k last
meeting
so when considering animal models carol
cautioned that researchers have to
critically reflect on the models
and the approaches that have been used
and challenge themselves as scientists
as to whether the animal
use is valid if it's translatable if
it's justified
i mean again these are all terms that
she was using well before
you know we use these in our common
vernacular today
and lastly good sensibilities this
refers to the capacity to respond to or
be affected by emotions or events
empathy for our research animals is a
prerequisite to the reduction of
suffering and she what she called the
life worth living for the animals
now in today's terminology sensibilities
has largely been replaced by the term
sensitivity care or the culture of care
and the paper that dr smith put out
reminds
us that this aims this concept of
culture care aims to improve animal
welfare but
also improve the condition of our animal
care workers
finally good sense good sensibilities
will promote good science and that's
ultimately what they hope to talk about
so next i'd like to move on to
historically then the next thing that
came along was in 1985
and these were the u.s government
principles the large title
is the principles for the utilization
and care of vertebrate animals
used in teaching research and training
and these were published in may of
1985 and they were part of an ongoing
change that was happening even with the
animal welfare act
for amendments in in around that time of
1985.
so just kind of step through these with
you the idea behind them was that we
needed to develop the knowledge
necessary to continue to improve the
health and well-being of humans
and animals and that would require in
vivo experimentation
so any u.s government agencies that were
going to be working on
animal research needed to abide by these
principles and they're really powerful
they're very succinct
they're published at the back end of the
guide for the careers of laboratory
animals
if you ever need to see them so first
and foremost transportation this was
kind of one of the main reasons that the
animal welfare act came into being
initially and the second principle that
has so much importance still today with
every experiment we think about is that
the procedures have to consider the
relevance to human and animal health
i love how that's partnered already in
1985
the advancement of knowledge and the
good of society and this will come into
play with some of our most recent
proponents
thinking about animal welfare we want to
consider the species
and alternatives we want to avoid
distress and discomfort
we have to use appropriate drugs so this
gets to refinements
and euthanize animals to limit any pain
and suffering
the seventh condition was to make sure
that there was a veterinarian involved
to help
look at the living conditions and ensure
they were appropriate
make sure everyone has been trained to
work with the animals
and lastly decisions of these principles
should not rest with the investigators
alone
but with an appropriate review group
such as the iacocc in consensus
so again just building along the three
r's we have a lot more detail
here to work with very powerful
statements that have continued to
leverage how we do our jobs in the
scientific enterprise
so again what was a really important
thing that happened in 1985
was that um again through the animal
welfare act the iacocca came into being
it's 35 plus years old now and each
registered research facility was
mandated that they had to appoint this
committee now at my institution
like many of yours we have a few
dedicated people that have to be on it
and then
at michigan state university we have up
to 20
all together to fill out the different
roles and have a really robust ability
to discuss
every animal proposal that comes before
us
so we have to have scientists we have to
have veterinarians
there are staff that are non-scientists
and very importantly there is
local and community public
so the number of things there are many
that this
committee is expected to do and it has
grown in time as the iacocca
enterprise itself has become its own
business we have to review the animal
activities
ensure compliance go and look at all the
facilities
maintain that training that was
mentioned in the us government
principles
and look at concerns about the animal
care and use
overall really have complete oversight
for the entire
animal care program and it also in 1985
the investigators were charged to
consider alternatives
and consult with veterinarians before
they would do their work
which was really critical as well we
still do veterinary consults on every
single proposal that comes our way
so as i mentioned the icon community
really grew and has grown for the last
30 some years
but interestingly it is one of the areas
where i feel like there is some
potential misuse or abuse of the 3rs
concept and there is some finger
pointing that happens at the ayakuk
somehow that they are not evaluating the
ethics rigorously enough
before approving use of protocols
the critiques that iacock are not
consistent across
institutions that i cox aren't
consistent in their deliberations
that we are putting members um really in
an impossible position i think is what
i'd like to state
it is impossible to set standards when
the people
and the expertise is going to differ
across committees
but flexibility was built into the
system early on so that consultants and
subject matter experts could always be
invited to assist in review with
discussions
and the last year alone i have been part
of chat's external to my institution
where i cooks have been blamed for the
reproducibility crisis
that somehow they aren't mandating
reduction of animal numbers
but that's a very limited view and i
want to be very clear and share what i
thought was such a perfectly stated
sentence that captures my feelings this
was stated on a call
in advance of this talk today by sally
todd sneratani
she said the ayakook was never meant to
be the ethical arbiter of animal science
and scientific
merit so why are we and others
potentially expecting them to be that
final ethical gatekeeper
to me those who may be placing blame on
the icon process and the reviews
maybe don't really understand all that
it entails
and that might be on us to have a more
transparent approach to clarify exactly
how decisions are reached about
approvals for animal studies
i think and believe that this
transparency would help not only the
scientists themselves
even at our own institutions understand
why their protocol
may be being held up for more review and
i think it would really help the public
and learn more about the science and
especially
inform the public that thinks there's no
review that we really do have a robust
process in place that considers animal
welfare
i just want to touch on this paper at
the bottom by stacy pritt
that just talked a little bit more about
this interplay
of ethics and how we can think about
things differently and how we work for
them
there's a lot to learn from this and a
lot of discussion still yet to have
so moving on then there was a very
important
issue of jlass this is one of the alas
journals that came out in 2015
and it helped me quite a bit in my
preparation for this talk
in particular this paper at the top um
um
by jerry tannenbaum and taylor benefit
bennett
i found it was a very comprehensive and
really a must read for those that are
interested in the three r's topic
i spoke with taylor as well in
preparation for this talk
what this paper did was really appeal to
promoting a more shared understanding of
those original definitions of the three
r's
in the context of what russell and burch
had proposed for their new applied
science
to look at the improved treatment of
animal welfare
specifically to improve treatments of
lab animals while advancing the quality
of science and studies
so the paper dissects the original
language as i said and parses the intent
and impact of interpretations
so they discuss each idea refinement
replacement and reduction
as originally intended and i want to
pause here and just comment on the term
reduction because this is the one r of
the three
that i feel is most misunderstood and
potentially misused and abused
so to quote the authors of the paper
the three earth's principles doesn't
define reduction as
minimization of the number of animals
used even though that is
really largely how we now define it in
fact russell and birch
emphasize that it's often impossible to
know in advance of an experiment
whether the minimal number of animals
will be used they
actually emphasize as we understand now
the importance of statistical
methodology
and they were advocating for this new
science as i've mentioned
so i want to demonstrate that the misuse
of reduction
has kind of become the refrain that i've
continued to hear
in recent years for those opposed to
animal research when they mention that
the three r's the scientific enterprise
is failing in their goals
if we stop and think about it aiming at
absolute minimization
is illogical in the face of experimental
design animals would be wasted
if too few are used and results then
wouldn't be able to be
interpreted or repeated we can also
think about reduction if we
flip the the switch to how expansive it
could be
to say that it's important for us to be
reducing the pain
and the distress and the stress and
maybe that's captured in refinements as
well
but it really could also be in reduction
so that's again
a charge to think about three hours more
expansively
and progressively in our approach
this issue as i mentioned came out in
march of 2015.
so the next thing i just wanted to touch
on that came out shortly after that
which was really important
again for how we think about science was
the four c's
the nih coin these and when studying sex
as
a variable to strengthen science we have
to consider
collect characterize and communicate so
women now account for roughly half of
all participants in nih supported
clinical research
and that is now subject to nih's policy
on the inclusion of women in clinical
research
the link here is included for you on
this slide
however more often than not it was
identified that basic and pre-clinical
biomedical research
largely focused on male animals and
cells from male animals
so this over reliance on males really
was found to obscure an
understanding of key sex influences on
health processes and outcomes
so it became mandated that females had
to be included in
certain studies and considering that
we need to realize that in essence could
have doubled the numbers of animals that
would be used
in different studies specifically and
that the nih wanted to
look at sex as a biological variable as
it was factored into designs
and the idea of which animals to use in
human studies
of course all of this still requires
strong justification from scientific
literature
preliminary data other relevant
considerations etc
if anyone's going to want to use more
than one sex
but investigators would be strongly
encouraged to discuss their issues with
nih
program officers and others prior to
submission of applications
but i do think the 4cs takes a lot of
the principles from the 3rs and expands
upon them
and makes them relevant as well
so in the concept of the 3vs this is
another one that came out and was really
important to the lab animal field
i just want to mention this was really
done as a design by hanoverville to look
at the harm benefit analysis
he believes that in this paper that if
studies do not produce results that are
scientifically valid and reproducible
then and that is something that we don't
want to have happen in the spirit of the
three r's
so in that case he was even pointing out
no matter how little harm was inflicted
animals still could be wasted with
inconclusive research
so his paper proposed that you would
think more specifically about design
looking at scientific validity he breaks
it down into construct validity
internal validity and external validity
and the scope of the animal experiments
as point was is often quite narrow we
have one laboratory
that's working on a very standardized
condition
and maybe only creates information that
can be repeated in that
laboratory so his goal was by talking
about
you know our efforts to minimize as part
of the three hours reduction we may
inadvertently be exacerbating this
limited data output
so his advocacy is really to have
repetition of experiments
potentially at multiple laboratories to
try to produce a more generalized
outcome to me this is fantastic in that
we must continue to increase
translatability to humans and animals
and this is a great
step forward in that and then moving to
the most recent addition to
our discussion about the 3rs this was
a book that came out just last year many
of you have probably seen it
the authors of it for the principles of
animal research ethics
are tom beechum and david degrazi who
are both preeminent
ethicists so i've looked through this
book i also have the benefit to talk
to taylor bennett about an alas
presentation
that mimi rogers and margaret landy put
on specifically
looking at this new ethical framework
and applying current case studies into
the six principles
so in short what they discuss here
are six principles three of which
evaluate social benefits
to humans compared to
the principles of animal welfare
and there's not much uh as far as the
explanations behind these i think it's
really interesting
what i really like about the text is
that there are a number of chapters that
they've invited authors
and well-known professionals and
colleagues to come and share their
stakeholder perspectives so there are
veterinary medicine perspectives
biomedical researchers
psychologists lawyers and bioethicists
that including lab animal vets that are
involved in this as well and it offers a
framework
that bridges a gap in their opinion
between
the concerns of both the biomedical and
the animal protection communities
there's a lot of press that came out
around this but importantly i want to
share some words from
mimi margaret's presentation these six
principles were not designed to
compete with or necessarily replace the
three r's although
there was quotation taken from the
authors that they felt like the three
r's were limiting and this was the next
step forward in their mind
toward thinking more holistically about
assessments um
so they reflect maybe a little too much
depending on that classic or limited
interpretation of the three r's
but i would in fact say that in the
contemporary 3rd
world we would want to include these in
our in our ongoing evaluation they're
just kind of another step down the path
as we continue to evolve our thinking
so for some artistic break then again
we've got our
what i would propose our progressive
three r's so in my umbrella analogy
with hands held underneath in um
in community really um the umbrella will
take on
the five freedoms it will include our
nine us government principles
it encompasses the four c's
the three s's the three r's the three
v's
and the six principles so in a
progressive state
as we brand this it's an acronym that
covers and includes
all the successive and related concepts
and i really again want to point out
that the stakeholders
everyone all the groups that are
involved in animal research to discuss
aspects of the 3rs holistically to work
through the ethics and discuss
the benefits so one
final thing i'd like to address in our
last few minutes together it's just
about the animals themselves because
this can often
be a critique somehow in our you know
very intense focus
nih focus on scientific efforts and
reproducibility
are we being attentive to the animals
themselves
so there have been and continue to be
advancements
in the care and quality for animals
these are mainly conducted by
caring devoted professionals who want
the best quality of life for the animals
and that makes good sense because we
want to have enriched and balanced
animal lives
that then provide really robust
scientific data
critics of the three r's often cite that
there's an inherent harm to animals
and that's a fallout of limited ethical
review however to that critique
i feel like we have to respond with data
and facts and show the information
that's been gained in veterinary science
and the involvement of veterinarians in
virtually every aspect
of contemporary animal use for research
purposes
so even just starting with something as
benign as the oath that veterinarians
take upon graduation
highlights the fact that we are charged
with advancing
medical knowledge along with making sure
that we are keeping the principles of
veterinary medical ethics at heart
in addition as mandated and as i
mentioned earlier
there are the requirements of
veterinarians
on committees being involved in the
review
one or more qualified vets has to be
it's must be
involved in the review and must be
involved in the iacook
so we have the authority to oversee the
vet care program and provide oversight
we help with things like disease
prevention diagnosis and control
we have to be available and look at
animals 24
hours a day we promote animal well-being
and we're also adhering to any of the
methods that might come out from the
avma the american veterinary medical
association
so we have a changing landscape in the
idea of animal research
landscapes in theory this is van gogh's
wheat field
is based on color theory so there's
different colors next to each other
and how you look at them alters the eyes
perception the strokes themselves are
expressive and sort of take on a
physical presence of their own that was
a style that van gogh had
so yes if you stand back and look at it
it's a wheat field
but it's so much more when you assess
the colors throughout and the individual
strokes
make the difference in the beauty of
this so i wanted to quote an analogy
from my colleague dr melanie graham who
i've been working with on a project
about the three hours who's also going
to be presenting
at this conference she is a very
well-known scientist who works with
non-human private primates
and what she shared is that the animal
welfare
that we're talking about isn't
necessarily a broad
concept it really happens at the
individual animal level
and that's what we're focused on she
notes intrinsic links between welfare
and scientific outcomes
that well-care for animals lead to
increased benefits of data outcomes
and again more translatable relevant
applications
so just to speak to this a bit there's
so much we could talk about related to
animal care and so many species here
of all of the pictures that i've pulled
from the internet here to show you
there is an emotional response sometimes
a physical response when we
view these we think about how these
animals are like us
we think about how they empathize with
us um interestingly
work from jeff mogul's lab has shown
that rodents are empathetic to one
another they have emotional contagion
we we need to learn more about their
intelligence
franz dewal has done amazing work
talking about how smart animals actually
are
elephants work together to find food
an octopus has been shown to be as
intelligent as a kindergartner
birds can make tools from objects to
you know build nests and things like
that too i mean it's really really
fascinating
and we're learning all the ways in which
opportunities can be provided to assist
with expression of species-specific
behaviors
this presupposes that we have insight
into what those behaviors are which may
not always be the case
but some recent lab animal science
information has shown that even just
giving enrichment to different species
will allow them to modify pain behaviors
and diminish pain more rapidly
particularly in rodent models
we've started the mandate for social
housing for social species
as this is a key welfare technique but
one that requires veterinary oversight
because some social species as you are
aware
will fight one another to establish
dominance
so the behavioral and the environmental
management techniques that ultimately
allow animals to adapt
we have to learn about those physical
and social conditions
and yet we're so pressured by the
current societal culture to just
continue to reduce numbers and replace
animals
we have to still study animals for the
sake of the animals themselves it's a
key consideration
so moving on from this then i'd just
like to share again back to our
progressive 3rs
we will have instances where the animals
then also fall under the umbrella
they will always be under consideration
and i think again in the
progressive model here we have plenty of
room to consider the animals
now i mentioned the progressive three
r's to you it's
um a terminology that that's been coined
that also could be synonymous with
contemporary
and i don't want to leave out crediting
the nc3rs site
and the you know committed individuals
that work on thinking about the same
concept as i mentioned in the beginning
of the talk i am just building on
you know what others have done before me
standing on the shoulders of giants in
this regard
so the contemporary thought would be
again we don't limit
what we think of these three words to be
we're looking at them in much more
expansive
interpretations and i would encourage
you to look at the nc3r
site to see this so for veterinary
medicine
we are doing research and it is
scientific research
and it's looking at all kinds of items
related to disease
therapies how to abide by refinements
looking into animal health knowing about
their behavior
this is all a very rapidly expanding
science and we translate this into
practical information that's critical
to continue to minimize pain and
suffering and also ensure
robustness and reproducibility for
experiments
so i just want to point out that this in
and of itself the idea
of veterinary management of animals will
continue to be
a massive area of discovery
there are a myriad of veterinary
journals animal science journals
professional seminars etc
that are looking at this specifically
and
these are evidence-based improvements
they are they are based in fact
we are in a very unique time as we all
know
and the pandemic itself offers
a great example for how to think about
animals
you know the idea that we need the right
model for the right question
it's the scientific process itself
that's going to drive our ability to
ultimately reduce animal numbers in
certain disciplines
for example the covid vaccine that a lot
of people have said oh well we didn't
need animals for that we just got it out
into humans as quickly as possible
they haven't got all of the data they
haven't got the information
that a lot of the work was done in
animals for sars
several years ago and now has been able
to be reused and adapted more quickly
from animal work that was done in the
past so
we do have an ethical obligation more
than ever to keep driving science
forward
and create new knowledge i think this
still goes back to
principle number two from the 80s
procedures should consider relevance to
human and animal health
advancement of knowledge and the good of
society
just mentioning here the harm benefit
assessment is it underlies everything
that we do
so a couple of quick things as we finish
up there has been
a pandemic pet proliferation there's a
lot of alliteration there
but i thought it was really important
this article just was shown out
a week ago in the michigan veterinary
medical association
and i know this personally i have not
acquired new pets but i have so many
friends and colleagues
that have and so when we think about
this we are not reducing animal numbers
we are creating animal numbers um not
only adoptions from shelters
adoptions from research institutions but
also from breeders
um this is what's happening because
science shows
that pets and humans
have incredible health benefits when
there are times of stress
and we've known this but again this is a
field of study that involves animals
social sciences and human work
so when we think about proliferation it
was timely then that
just last week in the last couple of
weeks there's been a big splash
about how many animals are too many um
you know what does it depend on is there
societal benefit to one but not another
and who gets to decide these things
so i wanted to just touch on the fact
that this article came out basically
stating
that um there's a hundred million
animals um it was based on a paper that
was
put together by dr larry caboni who is a
lab animal
veterinarian he made some estimates
based on data that he was able to get
through
conversations with colleagues and
through some foia requests
where he estimated that there were more
than 100 million mice and rats being
used in labs today
he acknowledged it was just an estimate
but from that
there were um in david grimm who's a
science writer
um he sort of pushed and i think maybe
glossed over
some of the important statements that dr
carboni placed into his publication
so he acknowledged that it was just an
estimate and he also stated
that that was about 99 of all the lab
animals were
rodent species he also pointed out that
there is a system of
inspections in place that we do
whistleblower investigations that there
is coverage and oversight for rodents in
public and private institutions and
those of us within the animal
biomedical community and who participate
in all of these activities
are well aware of these oversight
activities that i discussed
the iac review the vet consult
justification of animal numbers and
alternative considerations
but unfortunately in this summary i felt
like dr
carboni was glossed over by mr grimm on
these important statements
and kind of tilted the angle to animal
protectionists
there wasn't the facts there wasn't
accurate data everything was based on
estimations and he did
acquire a quote from the president of
alternatives to research and development
foundation
which their goal is to reduce the number
of animals in labs and find replacements
and her statement was the figures are
troubling because mice and rats aren't
covered by the animal welfare act
when we know they're covered by other
regulations
and her quote was if the numbers are
anywhere near correct the amount of pain
and suffering that's occurring in these
animals
acceptable myself and others find this
to be
like really sort of reckless
in a statement there was no information
provided as to the care and well-being
the models that these animals were used
for the oversights
the interventions so i just want to
echo my colleague dr allison bennett who
was also quoted in this science mag
article that she also agreed it was a
pretty disappointing analysis
we have to think about things more
broadly and we have to have more
discussion about them
so thinking about that if we were to
reduce animals
another area in our case studies for now
includes what type of rodent we're using
so the microbiome has been a very hot
topic
the microbiome is basically the full set
of flora that we have in our
gastrointestinal tracts and the
interaction between them
and our brain and other systems and so
wild mice
which normally many would consider to be
pests
there are whole businesses built around
getting rid of invasions of
wild mice and wild rats in our
communities and our homes and our farms
now there's going to be more of them
used in research analyses
so does that type of rodent what we use
does that matter to society
this will be an interesting and ethical
discussion ahead as well
and the last thing that i wanted to
point out which i just thought was a
really just a super cool article
was from the new yorker last month um it
talks about
and i think is a good example of the
progressive use of three of the three
r's
so crispr is commented upon here i
mentioned that um
that this is a 2020 nobel prize winner
as a technology
jennifer dunno was one of the recipients
from uc berkeley of the prize
as she's one of the developers and she
calls it a way to rewrite the very
molecules of life in which we live
so interestingly and briefly this
article
talks about how crispr has been used to
manipulate
the cane toad which is overtaking the
continent of australia
it was introduced to basically try to
control pests like bugs and things like
that
but evolution pushed quickly and these
cane toads grew very large there are
six plus pounds each and they have just
taken over
so gene editing using crispr is now
um available to change the skin tone of
the toads so that you can identify which
ones have been manipulated
you can also impact the fact that each
toad can give birth
or sorry it can lay like 1.5 million
eggs
explains the proliferation the problem
is that if we manipulate
the gel layer on the outside of the eggs
they may not be able to be fertilized
when these toads get big enough they
will eat anything and everything that's
smaller than them
including other smaller cane toads
snakes alligators etc
so in this idea of the progressive 3rds
we need to think about reduction
using science to reduce the number of
cane toads to allow the proliferation of
species that otherwise
are bordering on the brink of extinction
so the goals here
are to enhance biodiversity through
genetic rescue
and just kind of a fun a fun story
it's social benefit versus animal
welfare so these are the discussions we
continue to have
so for the future three r's i would
challenge us to think we're going to
continue to have more principles that
come into play as people talk about it
further
and we're going to have more species
like the cane toad that we have to
discuss we are all advocates
in this process every single one of us
if we're talking about it
we have an advocacy investment and so
what i just wanted to point out about
the importance of that
is that we want to take what we've
discussed here and make it better if we
can there are so many advocacy
organizations i'm going to list a lot of
them at the end of the talk
and we need to have this advocacy to
safeguard the future of biomedical and
veterinary research
involving animal models it would be
naive to assert that the only advocates
for animals are those in the animal
rights camp or in the animal protection
groups
our whole community drives momentum
towards animal advocacy
and we have to continue to do that for
beneficial outcomes
one comment i think many of you may be
aware that there is a
working group that's ongoing right now
i've had the privilege to be involved
with that through the nih
um this was charged as a group in
the late 2019 to come together and talk
about
assessing and making recommendations for
reproducibility and the rigor of animal
research
specifically to improve experimental
design optimize translatability
enhance training and increase
transparency these same themes
that i have been talking about and
showing you have been in
discussion since the 1970s
so we're continuing to look at gaps the
report should be coming out in june
of 2021 here we're still having meetings
about it and it will be something to
to look at on the horizon so the three
r's
are a masterpiece just as i'm showing
you here
these are self-portraits that van gogh
did
initially they were not regarded as
anything special and over time
they have become viewed as masterpieces
and what i wanted to show you here was
the progression in his work so from left
to right
um van gogh started off as kind of a
country living in the country with his
family and then he moved to paris and he
finally paints
himself as as an artist you can
appreciate that there's a change over
time and it is a triptych
again like our three r's the three r's
have remained ubiquitous in large part
because of their benefit to the animals
but they also have importance for
us as well the stakeholders so here's
the
is the icon that i've put together just
to express
how we can reconsider the foundational
or classic 3rs
with different interpretations very much
combining them with the synergy of other
ethical tools of analysis
and validity assessments that we've
talked about all of these are going to
be essential in the ongoing
intricate considerations of the
appropriate and future
animal use through artistic terms the
three r's themselves are also a
masterpiece
and they're a work in progress and i
hope we can all appreciate that
and continue the discussion so with that
i'd like to thank
the organizers for the lab roots
conference i had a lot of really
fascinating discussions and we'll
continue to do so with the colleagues
here from
lab animal medicine and preminer if you
want to take any arts classes i thought
i should just do a little plug for the
barnes museum
and all of the advocacy groups are
listed on the right
that i many of which i'm a part of and
many of which i've learned from
so thank you very much and i really hope
you enjoy the rest of the sessions